so we've been recently seeing a bunch of
rumors of apple working on ipads with
oled displays
and based on some of the comments i've
been seeing people are totally
misunderstanding the whole point of
bringing oled
to the ipad so before i get into what
makes the most sense for apple to do
i want to go through some of those oled
ipad leaks way back in november of last
year
the elec reported that apple would
release an oled ipad pro
in late 2021 which seems way too soon
after the mini led model
which just launched so that's definitely
not happening
and that's why a display analyst named
ross young
basically said nope to that rumor and
then a month later
barclays claimed that an oled ipad isn't
likely until 2022
at the earliest which makes much more
sense
and then finally in march we got our
first report from digitimes which
specifically mentioned
a 10.9 inch ipad being the first to get
an oled display
in early 2022 which can only be the ipad
air
which recently got upgraded with a 10.9
inch display
going even deeper digit times mentioned
that both oled
and midi led will exist side by side
each targeting different customer groups
which basically shows that oled
is not going to be replacing mini led
like some people think it will
and then later that same month ming
should quote basically confirmed what
digitime
said claiming that the ipad air will get
an oled display
in 2022 while mini led
will remain exclusive to the ipad pro
models
and the interesting piece of info that
he added was that using oled
would not cost more than the current lcd
display technology
used in the ipad but the most important
tidbit here
is that from apple's perspective mini
led will be
exclusive to the high-end ipad pro while
oled will be used on the lower end
ipad models which might not make sense
to some people
that believe oled is superior to mini
led
like in this comment from a few months
ago so before i explain the differences
between the two and why mini led is
actually superior
at least in apple's eyes let me finish
off with the most recent leaks and
rumors
back in may et news reported that apple
will be using oled displays in quote
some ipad models starting next year
which is interesting because it points
to other ipads
like the ipad mini and maybe even the
budget ipad
getting an oled display and then the
elec recently came back and agreed with
that report
claiming that apple will release an oled
ipad air
in 2022 and then release multiple oled
ipads
in 2023 and then finally the most recent
rumor that came just a couple of days
ago
from display supply chain consultants
is perhaps the most disappointing they
claim that the oled ipad air actually
isn't coming until 2023 which is a
pretty bold claim
considering everyone else says it's
coming in 2022
but if you think about it they're actual
display
experts that follow the field very
closely
and on top of that they claim that apple
will be cancelling the touch bar on
macbook pros in the future
which makes sense because the touch bar
is an oled display
that probably isn't showing up in the
supply chain
and this claim perfectly matches up to
rumors from both michiko
and mark german who said that the new
macbook pros
won't come with a touch bar so that
basically gives them extra credibility
with their prediction of an oled ipad
air
only coming in 2023 but regardless of
one we actually see at launch
let's now get into the controversial
topic of why oled
would be going into the lower end ipad
instead of the higher end ipad pros
first off the fact is that apple chose
mini led
instead of oled for their highest end
12.9 inch ipad pro
which shows that apple obviously thinks
mini led is better
so i did a little digging and i found a
comment on mac rumors forums
claiming that sony has stopped making
professional reference color grading
monitors
using oled technology this led me to
avsforums.com
where somebody confirmed back in 2019
that sony
is shifting from oled display tech over
to
a stacked dual layer lcd design for
professional reference displays
which is similar to the tech that apple
uses in their pro display xdr
and the mini led ipad pro and the very
first of that kind
was the sony bvm hx 310
which apparently was priced at 30 000
euros
and in hdtv test review of that display
he showed off that the contrast levels
are almost as good as a reference oled
display
while not having any blooming issues
whatsoever
he even said he can't believe it's not
oled
but then he showed off the brightness
differences using this
iconic scene from the matrix and the new
display
absolutely destroyed the oled display
and basically any other oled out there
because
oled is very limited in terms of
brightness
thanks to each pixel having to emit its
own light
so if you're curious what this means for
a tablet like the new mini led ipad pro
we actually compared it to samsung's new
galaxy tab s7 plus
which comes with a 120hz oled display
and the results are
shocking look at this massive difference
in brightness in this hdr video
with the ipad pro obviously on the left
compared to the oled display on the
right and this is weird because samsung
advertises this display as supporting
hdr
10 plus which means it needs to hit a
thousand nits of peak brightness
but the catch is that only a single
pixel
needs to hit a thousand nits to qualify
but in terms of full screen brightness
it can
only hit 484 nits peak brightness
compared to a thousand nits sustained
full screen brightness on the mini led
ipad pro
so just from watching this comparison
it's pretty obvious
why apple went with mini led instead for
the professionals
who want to actually edit hdr video
but that's not the only reason because
oled displays have a bunch of other
issues as well
check out all of these reddit posts with
users complaining about oled display
issues
like having weird tint screen uniformity
issues and
flickering at low brightness on top of
that
oled displays are known to give some
users headaches because of the pwm
tech required to make them work which is
something that many leds don't suffer
from at all
going even further oled displays can
suffer from burning
like you can see on this apple watch as
well as this iphone from an apple store
which has been left
too long on the same home screen page
once again
no issues with the mini led display so
if apple wants these ipad pros to be
used
for long professional editing sessions
mini led
just makes much more sense since it has
the least amount of drawbacks compared
to oled
so now with all of that said and
established
why would apple be giving the ipad air
an oled display instead of just going
for
the mini led display well because apple
obviously wants to keep their higher end
display
exclusive to the ipad pro to get people
to spend more money
like for example next year's 11 inch
ipad pro
is rumored to finally be getting the
mini led display
as well as a 12.9 inch but as far as the
ipad air
the reason it's getting oled is because
it desperately needs a boost
because apple recently raised the price
to 600
making it a bit of a worse value
especially since the m1 ipad pro was
recently released
packing in a ton of extra features
compared to the air
so in our recent buyer's guide video we
literally told people
not to buy the ipad air no matter what
either spend 200 more on the m1 ipad pro
or go for a less expensive model like
the budget ipad
which is only 300 right now on amazon
better yet just buy a refurbished 2018
ipad pro with 256 gigs of storage
for only 590 because that
old model is still way better than the
brand new ipad air 4
which lacks various features like hdr
video support
quad speakers 120hz refresh rate
and face id so what i'm trying to say is
that the ipad air
desperately needs something to make it
special again
and that is why the ipad air is getting
oled
along with reports that it won't really
cost apple any more money compared to
regular lcd
because it's going to use a rigid oled
design
and on top of that it's going to be
sticking to 60 hertz refresh rate
which means it won't be suffering from
many of those 120 hertz oled display
issues
that are currently plaguing the galaxy
tab s7 plus
but the ultimate end goal is micro led
which apple has been working on for many
years now and
it is going to be the best of all worlds
so if you want to see a deep dive into
how apple is going to utilize
micro led technology in their products
make sure to click that circle about to
subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right over
there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you